Well, well, well.
Lantern.
Are you going to copyright this one?
>> It's got
the
>> In light of things popping off with
Shake Man and myself, sorry, Shake Ran
and myself, it's been a hot topic of
debate. God logic chasing down Shikman.
Shik Uran running from God Logic
challenging him to a debate and not
showing up, hiding in the mosque. It's
all over Twitter, all over Tik Tok, and
it's all over YouTube, Instagram. It's
everywhere. It's big. It's huge. It's
loud. Muslims coming up talking about
it. Atheists talking about it. It's it's
all over the place. And conveniently,
ladies and gentlemen,
the Muslim lantern thought to finally
drop our video that we had almost 3
years ago. The video in which when I was
posting it, when I posted our
conversation, he decided to copyright
strike me so that I couldn't have it up
on my channel. But it wasn't just me
that he copyright struck. He struck
everybody that had the video downloaded
and uploaded our discussion after he
deleted it off his channel and didn't
show it. He made sure to strike everyone
who was posting our discussion on their
channels. I wonder why.
>> So you might be wondering why am I
uploading it today? Why I didn't upload
this conversation before? So the first
and most important thing is that this
guy when I had a conversation with him
had no clue who he was and it was barely
known on social media and I did sense as
you will see in the video this guy is
just coming for popularity fame to give
himself you know shout outs so people
can actually know who this guy is. So I
made sure not to give him what he was
looking for which is not uploading the
video not allowing him to have that
video in YouTube but sadly since then
almost all major duat have given him a
platform made him popular which is very
sad but I mean the case is different
today this guy is known so it's not the
same the second thing well it was an
interesting interaction
it was a very touchy subject the subject
that we were talking about was child
marriage within Islam and whether or not
he thinks that there is any immoral
action in having relations with a child.
And this is what he had to say to that.
>> My my question was, do you believe that
sex grow you know sexual relations with
a child and we understand what a child
is now uh at any point is is immoral.
Now notice he texts the answer adding
his little commentary on the screen and
he answers says yes if it causes
physical or psychological harm. That's
his answer. It is immoral to have
relations with a child if it causes
physical or psychological harm. Pay
attention to this.
>> I said to you the age is irrelevant.
situate determines it to be moral
immoral because your question is a moral
question. A situ determines something to
be moral immoral is is there physical or
psychological harm on the individual or
no?
>> When it comes to to children, you're
saying that as long as it doesn't hurt
the child, then it is then it is okay.
Sex child sex relations is okay as long
as it doesn't hurt the child. Is that
correct?
>> I didn't use that terminology. my
terminology. You can take it or leave
it. I don't I don't care.
>> I didn't use that terminology. You used
that terminology. You can take what I
said or leave it. I don't care. But
Muslim lantern, you just said, and you
even made it clear in the little text,
yes, it is okay to have relations with
little kids as long as it doesn't cause
them physical or psychological harm. So
why is it that you're contradicting
yourself when I repeat your words back
to you? You guys see what's happening
here? This is why he copyright struck
the video when I tried to upload it on
my channel when we did our discussion.
And all of a sudden now I guess when I'm
hot stuff back then they didn't want me.
Now I'm hot. They all on me. Now he
wants to go ahead and post a video and
it's doing pretty good on his channel.
I'm proud of you, man. And by the way,
it's posted on my Patreon for free. He
lied earlier in the video and said that
I posted it on my Patreon and that you
guys have to pay to watch it. No,
anybody can just go on the on my
Patreon. You don't have to be a paid
member and you can go watch the video
for yourself and you'll see why it is he
took down the video in the first place.
Mind you, when I joined the Muslim
lantern stream, he limited me to two
very small questions when he usually
allows for open dialogue and open
discussion for any non-Muslim that comes
on this panel. But for me, he had that
different energy and we're seeing why
once we get into the Jewish prudence,
what Islamic law has to say on this
matter. This is what he says when I
actually bring this up. I've studied
Jewish prudence more than you. So I know
the same. So I am correcting you. I am
correcting you there.
>> You're correcting me. So Muslim lantern
since you know the Jewish prudence more
than I do and you've studied this then
you wouldn't be afraid if I I don't know
decided to pull up what they said on the
matter what the four schools said
regarding relations with kids. You you
wouldn't mind if I pulled that up, would
you? Yes,
>> sir. So you know do you know the Jewish
prudence
>> on on this on this particular
>> on this issue? Okay so what did Im Shafi
say in his book about this?
>> Wait hold on so I I can pull up the
encyclopedia of jurist prudence where
they give
>> No. There's no such thing as an
encyclopedia of jurist prudence that
Muslims take to be to be reliable.
>> Can I share my screen then show you?
>> No no no share I don't know you're going
to show your screen.
>> What? I can't share my screen and show
you the evidence of where I'm getting my
stuff from. I can't show you the
encyclopedia of Jewish prudence when
they cover the issue of marrying a
little girl and having relations with a
little girl. I can't share it with your
audience so that we can all see what
they say. Really? I can't show you what
your scholars are saying. Huh? Why not?
Muslim lantern, you've studied the
Jewish prudence more than I have,
haven't you? But listen, I understand.
May maybe you know uh you you don't want
it. You you don't know what I'm going to
show. Uh maybe I'm some weird troll or
something. Let let maybe we can come up
with a different option. Yeah.
>> How about I send you the link and you
show it.
>> What link are you going to send?
>> I I'll send it to you and you
>> before you send it. What? What is it
that you want to show?
>> Okay. It it gives the ruling the ruling
from the four schools of juristprudence
on Marian.
>> Which website? Which website? Which
website?
>> Let me give it to you. It's from
dora.net. What is it?
>> R A.net.
>> Okay. I have never heard of this website
in my life.
>> Well, I'm sorry, Muslim Lantern, that
you're ignorant of the sources that are
out there and the websites that document
the information and put the books out
there for all of us to read. Thank God
we live in the age of the internet, but
unfortunately, it is the downfall of
Islam. So guys, we're at the point of
the conversation, he will not allow me
to show the source and bring it up,
which we'll get into uh later on in this
video, and I'm going to show you guys
why he did not want me to bring this
source up. But he was ignorant of the
source. He acted like he knew the Jewish
prudence, and he didn't know. Um, and
then he gets into the games. Now he's
about to ask me, "Oh, well, what are the
four schools of Jewish prudence?" Now,
now we're getting away from let me show
you what the document says. But let me
test let me test your memory now. Can
you name me the four SC uh the four
schools of Jewish prudence? And if you
can't name them off memory, then that
means you've never studied this. You
don't know what you're talking about and
yada yada yada. Take a look at this
really quick.
>> I don't think you even know. Can you
tell me the names of the four four
schools of Islam?
>> You have Hanafi. Without Google, without
googling, please. Can you can you move
your hand from the keyboard, please?
>> I'm literally going off I'm literally
going off memory. I'm literally
>> Yeah. Tell Tell me what are the names.
No, look at me. Look at me and tell me.
Please, please, please, please. Because
you study the Jewish princ. Please,
please don't do this because I respect
people who are honest. You can say I do
not know.
>> What? Look what I'm looking at right now
is
>> Google.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Can you look at me, please?
>> Can I send you the Can you look at me?
No. Okay. Can you tell me what is the
names of the Jewish again? You're
looking at the screen. I can see. Okay.
Tell me. two that I can off the top of
my head are shaf.
>> That's there's two that I
>> There are four. Look at me. Please,
please, please.
>> I just said that there's two that I can
name off the top of my head.
>> You don't even know the names of the
four schools of thought, which is a
basic baby child Jewish prudence will
know in Islamic studies. But you claim
you know the positions of the four
Jewish prudence schools that you don't
know their full names on this matter.
>> You see the games being played. So let
me not allow him to bring up the source
and the evidences that he has on him so
that we can actually progress in the
conversation. Let me play games and let
me play the what do you know and what do
you remember? Because even after this he
asked me do you know the the the actual
names of the of the people who originate
the uh schools of thought? Do you know
the like like just playing games and and
deflecting doing the biggest Muslim
shuffle of all time? Um but he flamed
himself because here's now this is his
argument guys. If you don't if you can't
remember something that means that you
don't know anything about it and you
haven't studied it. This is something
even kids would know and understand.
Well then you just buried Muhammad uh
Muslim lantern because according to the
hadith in Sai Bkari 5038 watch what it
says narrated Aisha Allah's apostle
heard a man reciting the Quran at night
and said may Allah bestow his mercy on
him as he has reminded me of such and
such verses of such and such suras which
I was caused to forget. Uhoh. Muhammad
forgot verses of the Quran. Muslim
lantern. So according to you, because
even kids memorize the Quran, don't
they? Can't even kids recite the Quran
from memory, word for word all over the
world. Well, Muhammad wasn't able to. He
forgot portions of the Quran. Which
would mean according to your standard
that Muhammad didn't know anything about
the Quran. He didn't really study the
Quran. He didn't really uh uh he didn't
know what he was talking about with the
Quran and with Gabriel, right? Muslim
mentor, thank you for burying say
bye-bye Muhammad. Such stupid arguments
with stupid games that the double guys
have to play in order to save face in
front of their audience. Now, let's get
into the source that he was so afraid of
me sharing because I I offered I can
pull it up or I can send it to you and
you pull it up if you don't trust me.
You can look at it first and then pull
it up for your audience. He didn't even
do that. We never got to the point where
we show the source. So, guess what,
Habibi? We're going to show it here. So,
when we open this up here, we got
dar.net net which has the Encyclopedia
of Islamic Jewish Prudence. He said
there's no such thing as this. Yes,
there is. Sorry, Muslim lantern. The
Encyclopedia of Islamic Jewish Prudence.
And their issue is they're dealing with
the ruling on marrying a minor girl. You
see that, ladies and gentlemen? The
ruling on marrying a minor girl. Now, it
isn't just a resounding no, don't you do
it. No, they give reasons why it is
permissible. Watch this. The first
issue, a father marrying off his young
virgin daughter. A father may marry off
his young eldest daughter without her
permission.
This is agreed upon by the four schools
of Islamic Jewish prudence. What? Avery,
you were correct,
huh?
the Hanfi school,
the Malachi school, the Shafi school and
the Hanballes.
And consensus was reported on that. So
they all agreed all the four schools of
Jewish prudence, the ones who's giving
law and giving decree, they agreed that
it is permissible to marry off a minor
girl without even her permission as long
as the father says so. Now, what's the
evidences that they give, you might ask?
What where are they getting this from?
Oh, I'm glad you asked that question.
The evidence first from the book. What
book? The Quran. It quotes Al Talak.
Verse four, chapter 65:4 of the Quran.
And those of your women who have uh
despared of ministration, if you have
any doubt, then their waiting period is
3 months. and those who have not
menrated. So, the elder women, when
you're divorcing them, the elder women
have a three-month waiting period to
make sure she's not pregnant if you fear
that she might not be getting uh having
her ministration anymore. And the same
waiting period goes for the girls who
have not ministrated yet. They've never
ministrated. They're too young. And they
also have a waiting period when you
divorce them. Divorcing little girls who
haven't even hit puberty yet, y'all.
Four schools of thought. This is their
evidence. Now, what's the point of this?
It is that God Almighty has ruled that
divorce of a young girl who has not yet
ministrated is valid and divorce only
occurs within a valid marriage.
Therefore, the verse implies the
permissibility of of a of of a young
girl. And there is no authority with
whom marrying a young girl uh her
marriage is valid except if her father
marries her off. As long as the father
says it's cool, then it don't matter.
Now, that's their first evidence. The
Quran, the Quran, that's their first
evidence. What's their second line of
evidence? The Hadith, Muhammad's
character is their second line of
evidence. Watch this from the sunna the
may God be pleased with him. So the
prophet may God be pleased with him
married her. So this is what Aisha says
on the authority of Aisha that Muhammad
married her when she was 6 years old and
she was brought to him when she was nine
and she stayed with him for 9 years.
What happened here? Muhammad consummated
the marriage with Aisha when she was a
nine-year-old little girl. That's their
second line of evidence. What's the
point of this evidence? This is explicit
in permitting a father to marry off his
young daughter without her permission
because she has no right to give
permission. Do y'all hear that? She has
no right to give permission. four
schools of thought. Your jurist prudence
in consensus that it is okay to marry
off and sleep with consummate the
marriage with little girls who have not
yet hit puberty which you said I you
according to you you said it's okay as
long as as long as it don't hurt her as
long as it doesn't cause physical or
psychological harm it's all good. It
don't matter what age she is. She could
be four, five, three. If it don't hurt
her, if she could take it, you can break
it. You see how disgusting this religion
is? You see why he didn't want me to
read his sources and his scholars? Well,
it gets better, guys. Watch this, ladies
and gentlemen. This is from Islam Q&A,
and they're quoting the scholars.
They're quoting the sources in the
Jewish prudence. Watch this. The fact
that it is permissible to marry a young
girl does not mean that it is
permissible to have intercourse with
her. rather that should not be done
until she is able for it. Hm, I wonder
what that means. For that reason, the
prophet delayed the consummation of his
marriage to Aisha. Al-Nawi said with
regard to the wedding party of a young
married girl at the time of consummating
the marriage, if the husband and the
guardian of the girl agree upon
something that will not cause harm to
the young girl, then that may be done.
If they disagree then Ahmed and Abu Oade
say that once a girl reaches the age of
nine.
Then the marriage may be consummated
even without her consent.
But that does not apply in the case of
who is younger. Malik al-Shafi
and Abu Hanifh said the marriage may be
consummated when the girl is able for
intercourse. I wonder how they're
figuring out that. How are they finding
out if the girl is able to handle it or
not? H look at this religion which
varies from one girl to another. So no
age limit can be set. This is the
correct view. Ah man, sorry Muslim
lantern tough. There is nothing in the
hadith of Aisha to set an age limit or
to forbid that in the case of a girl who
was able for it before the age of nine.
Get what they're saying? There's nothing
that forbids consummating a marriage
with a girl before the age of nine. She
could be eight, seven, six,
as long as she is able to handle sexual
intercourse.
If she's able to handle it, then you can
go ahead and sleep with her. This is
Islam. And this is why that coward, that
clown, Muslim lantern did not want me to
show the sources of his scholars on the
Jewish prudence and the ruling on this
issue or to allow it in the case of a
girl who is not able for it and has
reached the age of nine. Al Dawoodi said
Aisha was reached physical maturity.
Yeah, right. Al-Nawi said, "It should be
noted that Al Shafi and his companions
said it is preferable for the fathers
and grandfathers not to marry off a
virgin until she reaches the age of
puberty." And they ask her permission.
See, all of this is preferable. Not
that's not the ruling, but this is what
is suggested. Lest she end up in a
marriage that she dislikes.
What they said does not go against the
hadith of Aisha because what they meant
is that they should not marry her off
before she reaches puberty if there is
no obvious interest to be served that
they fear will be missed out on if they
delay it as in the hadith of Aisha. In
that case, it is preferable to go ahead
with the marriage because the father is
enjoined to take care of his child's
interests a and not to let a good
opportunity slip away.
And Allah knows best. Trust me, Muslim
lantern, I understand. I I understand
the hesitation to let somebody like me
on your channel and have a full-on open
discussion and we share thoughts and we
share views and we share sources because
you are in danger of being embarrassed,
being humiliated and uh having your
religion exposed. So I I I get it. I
I've I've dealt with someone very
similar uh within the past few days
actually. Reminds me you remind me of
him. And because you remind me of him,
you are on my radar now, just like he
was. So this is what I offer for you
since you decided to post a video right
after all this heat that has been going
on. I would openly invite you to come to
my stream or we can go on a neutral
platform like modern day debates or the
gospel truth and let's actually have an
open discussion or we can debate this
formally on child marriage within Islam
or on the morality of Islam. Is Islam a
moral religion? Let's actually have a
discussion where you can't talk over me
and corrupt my mic when you talk over me
when I'm talking and uh we can actually
share our sources and you can't hide the
information from your audience. We up
now. So, let's go ahead and do it. Let's
do it. You and me oneon-one. Let's have
a discussion, an open discussion. What
do you say?